outgoing District of Columbia council
member Kevin Chavis argues that charter
schools are a model for educational
reform in his new book serving our
children this talk from caribou books
and Hyattsville Maryland lasts an hour
ten minutes greetings welcome to career
books and Molly Prince George's today we
present to you the ward 7 representative
on the council of district columbia he
also served as the chair of the
committee on education libraries and
recreation and as an advocate for
charter schools and the reform of f of
american public education kuriboh books
represents custom and Kevin Shabazz with
his book serving our children thank you
thank you very much Thank You charas and
I want to thank the folks at caribou
books and particularly Lee MacDonald for
supporting what we're trying to do I I'm
glad each of you could come I thought
I'd do a couple of things today I I
wanted to share a little bit about my
background and how I came to be so
passionately involved in the issue of
what we're doing to and for our children
in education in the area of Education
and then I wanted to share a little bit
about what I think each of us could do
because it is to me is the seminal issue
in America we need to come to grips with
you know I'm on the DC Council and
winding down my third term and I chaired
the Education Committee and people often
ask me how did I get involved in public
service in politics and then how did I
come to write this book well I think
it's one of those things where it was
part of my journey i was born in a
household that really focused on the
importance of education and and the need
for being able to read write and count
so you could really compete that was
what i was brought up with from my
father and my mother and I carried that
over to to go into law school when I
graduate from Howard law school and I
passionately believe in public service I
thought public service was the
requirement to
much is given much is expected and and
eventually I ran for public office
thinking that I could make a difference
but a funny thing happened on my way to
public service I realized that public
service is not just making sure that you
get your fair share of city services but
it is really about making sure that
people have an equal opportunity to do
for themselves and the evolution of my
public service led me to really focus on
the fact that all the negative social
dynamics facing our community is
directly traceable to a lack of quality
education I mean everything from you
know teenage pregnancy to unemployment
to drug abuse you know if you look at
the statistics wherever you have an
educated population you have a limited
number of all those negative social
indices and so a few years back I
realize how important education was and
I decided to take over the chairmanship
of the Education Committee on the City
Council and it was amazing to me when I
started to look at what's really going
on in public schools because you know a
lot of people say education is important
but they really don't know what's going
on day to day in our schools an RM each
of our schools is really the image that
we we remember when we were kids and you
know sometimes there's a big gap you
know that there can be a 1020 in some
instance 30 40 year gap and that's why
people were tied two buildings and
memories as opposed to today's reality
and I decided to write this book largely
because I thought it was important for
people to get a snapshot in the window
of what today's schools are really like
but more importantly what they have the
potential of being so serving our
children really chronicles my experience
in in my journey and frankly my growth
my evolution if you will to to believing
that public education and a high
quality public education can be had for
for every child and but in order for
that to occur we need to face some
realities before I take some questions i
do want to read a little bit of read
from the book but you know as I approach
this this task of trying to formulate
education policy that makes sense I told
myself I was going to be practically and
intellectually honest about what we're
facing and make no mistake about it in
rural America in suburban America and
urban America public education is broken
we can't apologize about that anymore
and we can't be dishonest about it if
you are an african-american child in the
fourth grade then you have a six out of
ten chance of not being able to read a
grade level and those are charitable
numbers if you enter high school in any
city in America you have probably at
best a fifty percent chance of
graduating from high school now to me we
all should be outraged we should be
ashamed and frankly we should be
embarrassed and and and looking at why
public education is broken and it's not
just an urban America problem as I said
if you look at why public education is
really broken it really is because we
have an outdated model that is not
suited for today's kids now think about
it and I talked about this in the book a
lot of people don't even realize that
the education model that that most of us
know about was put in effect during the
industrial revolution back in the 1800s
in fact the whole 9 23 schedule of
school is based on you know getting the
kids you know it's coo at nine so they
could work in a field early in the
morning getting them out at three so
they can get out enough time to go back
in the field and have the summers off
they can work in harvest the field all
summer that's where the schedule came
from and even the the whole idea of when
you learn and at what pace you learn
that is ill-suited for today's his I
generally asked a question when did most
of you I'll take algebra if you remember
that far and you know I have to think
back and and most you will say ninth
grade because that's when algebra was
offered in most public schools ninth
grade oh well does that make sense
because your your your mother probably
took it in knife making your grand
mother took it at night maybe your
great-grandmother took a ninth grade
what's wrong with if you have some
natural proclivity toward math and
science technically seventh grade or
maybe sixth grade or maybe you should
have your schedule Justin take you to
tenth grade see that one size fit all
approach to public education I think has
been a big failure for our kids because
it doesn't allow for innovation and
creativity to enter into to educating
our kids the other thing that really is
wrong with public education honestly
speaking is the bureaucracy you know the
system the system of public education is
one of the biggest barriers to our kids
learning in that system is so
self-protecting that you may have a
thousand people or two thousand people
working downtown in a school district
administrative office and before any
resources get to the neighborhood school
it has to go through layers and layers
of people to sign off on it so if if in
your local school you need a substitute
teacher or you need books and supplies
or you want to even rent out your
gymnasium you've got a requisition
downtown and get four or five people to
sign off on it
that that bureaucracy gets in the way of
kids learning and that's something that
that that needs to change so in my book
I talk about in serving our children I
talk about how we've really gotten to
the point where the sameness of what
we've been doing has had a stranglehold
on creativity and charter schools as
we've learned in DC the biggest value
they give us is that the tools for
chains see the goal should be this each
and every child in America should have
access to a high quality education
that's the overriding goal now what are
the tools we need to put in place to
help us achieve that goal if we know
that the one-size-fits-all model doesn't
work that it doesn't work for every kid
then the tools should be flexible enough
to meet the needs of individual children
just like we all have our differences we
all have our similarities you know to
force every child to learn in the same
way in the same manner at the same time
it's not fair to that child so charters
in DC for instance if it has allowed us
to do some things out of the box that
otherwise wouldn't happen for instance
in the book as I talk about you know
public education generally and then the
birth of charter schools around the
country and then in DC I've talked a
little bit about the history of public
education in DC but then then I get into
some detailed discussion about selected
charter schools in DC that offer some
innovation some that a lot of people
don't even know about like the seed
public charter school which is the first
residential charter school in the
country you have a 150 boys and 150
girls living 24 hours a day on a college
campus like setting and learning and
some of these kids come from solid
stable homes but some of these kids come
from challenge backgrounds
and it is to their best interests to be
in a nurturing college preparatory
residential school that type of
innovation you you really be hard
pressed to get in the traditional system
another charter school we talked about
Cesar Chavez charter school which is the
first public policy charter school in
the country where they have hundreds of
partnerships with federal government
agencies with embassies with trade
associations with nonprofit groups and
they they have a development officer
they have a career counselor there they
have someone on site who coordinates the
hundreds of volunteers that come through
that school every week and these kids
are immersed with all kinds of public
policy experiences that very few kids
get see I think that the biggest
contribution that charters and the issue
of choice as a whole can offer to
American public education is to force us
to think about it differently because
people say to me well you know
councilman are you you just so pro
charter or you're so pro school choice I
said no I'm really more than anything
pro kids and and and and I'm honest
about that and I'm honest about the fact
that if we know what we're doing isn't
working for all kids then what are we
doing in response to make sure that all
kids are able to learn uh and the other
thing I tell people I'm not hostile to
public schools I believe in public
education I think frankly this will help
push public education to do things that
it has not been doing one question I get
all the time and I talked about it again
in the book it's what about the money
issue that you know charter schools take
money from public schools
they're all public schools charter
schools are public schools and if if we
do what I I know we did in DC which i
think is going to also make a difference
where we tie the funding to public
education to individual children based
on a per pupil spending allotment then
the money will follow the child which is
the way it should be as opposed to
putting hundreds of millions of dollars
in the hands of a handful of
administrators to sense to dole out and
distribute the way they see fit then
let's make sure we have that lump of
money allocated on a per pupil basis so
if you have 300 kids in your school then
these are the dollars you're going to
get be a charter school or a traditional
traditional public school i also want to
to share before i read this one passage
of something i think we all need to be
more aware about and that is this idea
of fixing our schools is not just one
that we should rely on our policy makers
or elected officials or quote unquote
leaders to be involved in I think that's
been part of the problem I think we all
need to be involved there should be a
national crusade sent it around school
reform issues in effect we we all need
to be educated about what's going on in
education I can tell you I was on the
City Council for four or five years and
I really did not know about what was
going on in our schools until I started
to visit our schools and talk with
people and read more about it we need to
challenge the rhetoric from the
presidential candidates on down when
people run for office they say education
is number one priority and I guarantee
you that when most are elected they
aren't involved in education issues I
know in fact in every legislature in
every state house
in Congress they're just a handful of
elected officials who know anything
about what's going on in schools yet
everyone says it's a number one priority
but you know very few people were hands
on the battle CJ you got a challenge the
rhetoric when people talk about even
complex issues not like the utility or
the problem with No Child Left Behind
you need to know at least enough about
it to challenge their views because
sometimes they they campaign on it but
they don't actually understand the
issues the politics of Education I think
we all need to respect the politics but
not be political when it comes down to
the ultimate opinions we have about
what's best for our children the same
with ideology people can be Republicans
or Democrats or conservatives or
liberals but we don't need to be
ideologues we don't need to be
extremists that's just that are just
tied to the party politics so I'm going
to support this because the Democrats
tell me too and when it comes to
education I'm going to support this
because the Republicans tell me to that
that that doesn't work I mean we use the
phrase we should we should support and
live the purity of the phrase what's in
the best interest of children that
really is what guided my my journey of
my growth I want to take some questions
before i do i'ma grab the book I I say
this when I talk a lot about it as I
said the book chronicles some of my
personal experiences in and and
vignettes and dealing with children and
dealing with schools but in the book in
the last chapter I say is hope for the
future so I'm going to read this and
then I'll take some questions because in
spite of all the problems we we hear
about schools there is hope in terms of
what needs to happen I once visited a
middle school not far from a public
housing community in my ward for a
national honor society
ceremony about ten seventh and eighth
graders were being inducted into the
National Honor Society one girl a
seventh grader was sitting in the back
row on the stage directly behind me in
an old yet neatly pressed skirt and
white stockings without shoes she was
self consciously trying to hide the fact
that she didn't have shoes I later asked
one of her teachers why she wasn't
wearing shoes I was told that the child
only own one pair of tattered tennis
shoes and no dress shoes she was so
proud of her induction to the Honor
Society though that she refused to spoil
her day by wearing an old pair of tennis
shoes with her nice skirt and blouse she
chose instead to attend with no shoes at
all often it doesn't take much support
or a tremendous amount of incentive for
our children to be steered in the right
direction what has been most troubling
with some of our traditional
institutions is that they fail to give
many of our kids any support in spite of
all the problems found in the American
public education system hope does spring
eternal for one primary reason the
resiliency of our children I've run into
countless examples of children who come
from dysfunctional home settings and who
have received limited if any nurturing
along the way and they still have an
inner drive to excel and succeed these
children demonstrate daily and
indomitable spirit that guides them
through their hardships often the
determining factor about their eventual
ability to exist to succeed or fail is
reduced to one or more positive
influences in their lives our
traditional public education system must
recognize that the new realities of our
society dictate a dynamic diversified
approach to the way children are taught
and treated in our schools one single
approach no longer works for all
children just as diversity of population
is one of the greatest strengths of this
country diversity of educational
options and experience will help start
meaningful change in public education I
end with that because I do think in
spite of all of our fights over what's
right for kids you know at the end of
the day they sometimes end up being
adult Wars where we fight over what's in
the best interest of kids and all we got
to do is show a little love and support
and these kids will grab it and take
hold of it the young lady that I refer
to the seventh grader I did come to
spend some time with was very proud of
the fact that she was a straight-a
student and was not one of those kids
who shied away from her award and
obviously we were able to help her and
get some shoes and support for her but
she came from such a tragic challenged
background but that internal spirit and
drive was there and I think the message
that I really wanted to close the book
out with is it is essentially that that
you know a little bit goes a long way
with these kids and and we don't we
don't even appreciate how far they can
go with just a little bit of support and
help and nurturing from russ and and
that is really what was guided my my
public career and my views on schools I
think charter schools begin to push us
in the direction of thinking a little
bit differently about the best way to
educate our kids so I thank you very
much i want to take some questions I
know I got a little bit long-winded but
I really appreciate you all coming out
this evening yes sir I grew up in our
Washington positive public school yeah I
found out he got louder easily the best
food everybody won't go to Roosevelt I
want to do that it's something we would
change the area code this sorted
children can go to a better school right
and I was in high school was left with
charter schools with the money for those
people compassion they ain't gonna be
able to pay for charter schools
trying to say it the public schools is
suffering and my brother said my nephew
to a private school these candidates and
everything know anyway bring a long
story short and I have books I graduate
1990 my in the books think that 1970
everybody worked their name all into 70
all the good books go to the schools are
doing the best population about all the
poor stuff I don't be going final as my
teacher had the Xerox are okay paper
friend alone paper Xerox Contessa and we
have to write it down and give him back
the copy because the school was so
deprived but who today the teachers made
the best out like they did it's not the
teachers fault but the resources it's
not getting to you guys the computers
are in the upper class room I mean the
charter school but really I can critters
in that but i think the uniform would be
best because everybody fighting in for
clothes and jewelry right at the uniform
school everybody everybody wearing the
same thing they couldn't join or even if
they buy your hurt somebody feeling yeah
i think beautiful schools we do best
well I think you're right you know
what's interesting is when I talked with
folks about what's going on schools they
grab hold of those kind of issues about
resources like they say well how come
some schools get this and and other
schools don't and I think the big the
big problem is that the system that we
are used to is so used to allowing the
politics of manipulation to grab hold of
resource allocation and and and and
that's a complicated way of saying the
squeaky wheel gets the oil you know that
that if you come from an area where
you've got some politically active
parents you'll get your fair share but
it shouldn't work like that see the way
it should work is if you're a child and
I don't care where you grew up or what's
your socio-economic background answer
who your parents are if you're a child
and you're presented to the public
school system for an education then you
should be able to get it by the time
you're three or four you should be in a
certified qualified early childhood
development program they should be able
to do assessments about where you are by
the time of year in thirty fourth grade
you should be reading at grade level if
there are issues at home then there
should be some some companion
relationship and I talked about this in
the
with social services so you can have
home study set in you can have you have
counseling services but it doesn't work
like that it doesn't work like that
because you have the folks from upper
income school districts being able to
put pressure on school officials to get
their fair share and you've got low
income folks who don't have the
wherewithal to know what even questions
to ask you know having to accept less
and you know the expression i use is
some folks don't even know what they
don't know i mean you can't even be an
advocate for your kid if you never got
it yourself so the system has to be set
up in such a way you you've got these
independent forces working to make sure
every child every child's needs from an
educational standpoint is assessed and
then they can get their fair share yeah
yet we go very yes what is the role of
special interests in charter school
before you mentioned that upper income
parents yet soccer moms have time to go
to PTA meetings whereas low-income
parents may not what are some of the
other special interest groups that are
affecting the ability to make some of
the changes that you see well I mean I
think honestly special interests have
had a stranglehold on public education
and you know people always asking about
the unions I mean I think I support
teachers I think you know we've got
teachers in this country I know in my
area in southeast and northeast DC we've
got teachers who but for them a lot of
these kids wouldn't make it because they
come from challenge backgrounds and my
heart goes out to them but I also know
it in some cities and in some school
district union rules alone have a
chokehold on even what teachers want to
do giving an example one of our former
superintendent was complaining to me and
the mayor in DC about the fact that the
teachers union want to insist on a
clause and I mentioned this in the book
where a teacher had to leave the
building by 3 15 even if they wanted to
stay
and some of the young teachers wanted to
stay to help with after-school programs
and mentoring but here you had a union
rule telling them you need to leave and
and and that doesn't make sense you know
I believe in fair wages I believe that
you know teachers should be getting paid
a lot more as 11 colleague wrote a book
you know the hundred-thousand-dollar
teacher and his premise was that every
teacher should start out with the
minimum of a hundred thousand dollar
salary I don't have any problems with
that as an ocean but I do think that the
special interest rules governing the
bureaucracy has caused a big problem and
and I think we need to be open enough so
that we can we can we can put that
second to what's in the best interest of
the kids and and so that's that's just
the way I feel about that yes ma'am
comment and that's the question I really
as a charter school parent appreciate
the support encourage that you had in
supporting charter schools has made a
tremendous difference from my son who's
a fourth grader right now who I used to
a world he's doing it subtly sweet such
a separate level wow he some is made a
huge difference for him just having at
the choice of the neighborhood school or
any other charter school we wanted to
those are we were able to really
customize an education for our decision
of the question I'm going to ask was
how do you respond and how the parents
respond to all the negative press comes
that's out there about charter schools
are particularly pitting them against
additional public school well that's
that's a good question because I get it
all time first of all I think we need to
really have more aggressive education
and information campaign about what
charter schools are I mean charter
schools are public schools they get
public dollars they're accountable to
the public the difference between
charter schools and traditional public
schools is that they don't report to a
superintendent of schools they're not
part of a school district per se in most
traditional public school districts you
have one superintendent who is
responsible for a bunch of schools in DC
is 146 schools that the one
superintendence responsible for charter
schools are autonomous and and when they
when when a group of people sit down and
say we want to start a school they have
to go through a rigorous application
process they have to create a board of
directors and concludes community folks
and business folks and and local
education leaders they have to submit
that application to the public charter
school board or the DC Board of
Education in different states that have
charter school lols it varies who they
submitted to and then it is a very
rigorous intensive application and then
if it's approved then they're given a
charter for five years and they have to
meet their goals and timetables what's
great about that process as opposed to
the way we used to delivering public
education services it's pure
accountability if you don't follow what
you say you're going to do you lose your
charter and its crew shuts down and in
in the book I talk about some schools we
shut down and they should have been shut
down because if you make a promise on
how you're going to educate kids and you
don't live up to it you should not run a
school I mean I wish we could shut down
some of these schools that have been bad
for years but we can't mess with them
and then people get tied to the building
well you know
mama went there my grandmother over
there y'all can't close that school but
kids aren't learning y'all still can't
close that school so I mean I think that
that one is the education process that
is public dollars you know tied to
children's enrollment there's
accountability and and the other thing
is the best way to I think analogize it
you know none of us in this room is
wearing the exact same thing none of us
we all have different tastes we all have
different shapes sizes we all have
different things that are attractive to
us we all respond differently to
different types of dress and attire and
and there's nothing wrong with that in
fact that diversity those different
interests is really what makes the world
great so why should we put every child
in the same educational box this is the
only area in American life where we
force kids to do things the same way
we're force people to do that you know
you have different options on phones on
clothes on cars on houses on what you do
this is the only area where you say you
got to take algebra in ninth grade you
got to take history at this time you got
go from nine to three what's wrong with
the 24 hour residential school what's
wrong with an all-male school or in our
female school what's wrong with
year-round school in some instances
what's wrong with school on Saturday I
mean it may not be for all kids but
maybe for some kids because if you're a
parent and you know this and I know
meeting long-winded so bear with me but
if you're a parent and you got two three
kids it don't take long to figure out
dem kids are different it don't it don't
take long to figure out you can't use
the same approach I know I have two sons
and what I do with my older son I can't
it may not work with the younger son and
even the way they learn i mean my older
son and i don't want to embarrass them
in case they watching but
but my older son he responds differently
and learns differently but because you
know my wife not been you know hands on
his parents we picked up on that now if
we had tried to force that same approach
with the younger son it wouldn't have
worked so i do think that part of it is
making sure that folks understand that
the issue of choice you know where you
go to public school of public charter
school or a private school you know some
people now doing homeschooling I mean
that's the best that's one of the
biggest growth areas in the country
we're more and more parents or educating
kids at home because they they're very
frustrated with what's going on so but
that may be okay for some kids you know
that may not work so I think whatever it
is we need to educate people about it
and then then then we've got to put
pressure on the so-called powers that be
to make sure that there is receptivity
to doing things a little different I'm
gonna come back to you my man but you
first yes lady I'm son my daughter is a
student at sea charts ago and which ones
see charts so see okay um it's a nice
goal but it could be better friends I
find that when all the skills public my
charm school district puts the emphasis
on bringing children up to their reading
level her but my daughter doesn't need
that my daughter when she went to
kindergarten her kindergarten had her
helping her teach the kids how to read
so she's basically left on her own and
she gets bored easily so she just had
been doesn't participate jeanneau she
wait until like the end of the grading
period and they should do all the work
internally at one time and paste right
oh yeah you know what I'm glad you
raised that because you hit on what I
think is the one of the biggest
challenges we're facing even with our
good schools because see because
American public education has started to
fall down so much and test scores are
going down and more than test scores
kids aren't learning and you know kids
aren't graduating because of all of that
there's been this real focus on
remediation and and bringing kids up and
bring these up and for
a child or parent of a child who is
exceptionally bright as it sounds like
your daughter's that's where we're
really falling behind so you know we
really need to focus one of the things
that we've been encouraging people to do
is starting schools for the talent and
gifted for you know those who are
proficient in math and science you know
taking it schools that offer more
advanced AP courses because that is an
area where because of all the literature
and all the experience we have with kids
who are so far behind a lot of people
were starting schools now they're
putting all their focus on making sure
they bring these kids up to standards
and if you're naturally bright you know
you're going to get bored you know and
and so we do need to make sure that we
we have just as many offerings for
children like your daughter and I think
again that this is the way in with the
school district when they have either
these true magnet schools not what I
call the fake me out magnet schools but
the true magnet schools and and and true
schools to help take care of the needs
of kids who are who are talented gifted
I think that would help yes ma'am engage
you on a deeper level about the charter
school yes I have to admit that my own
attitude about them
is that they are there fail they fail us
too they fit let's do and this account
because of the accountability you speak
up they really are not held to an
accountability standard the public
schools are and many of them can engage
your interest but the test scores of the
children some of them fall apart in the
middle of the year they're sent back
into the schools which makes an impact
on whatever comes their sit back into
now what does what what does a charter
school you know bring to the table you I
certainly no one would disagree with you
about the approach but you spend a lot
of time on your say in your book of
diversity a diverse approach is
marvelous right but if it doesn't result
in good test scores for the children
it's in the same place in public school
a poor public journey would be because
diversity in and of itself does not
bring excellence yeah we're all sitting
here yes nobody addressed a life but so
doesn't that free well I agree i'm
saying so the account the account the
thing that bothers me about those
charter school is how many of them get
away with him see once okay i'm getting
excited to the question is so many of
them get away with whatever i don't know
how rigorous this this application
process is because a lot of them get in
there and they are stealing money from
the city or from the schools they are
stealing the money because the program
they have is not there the buildings
they promise is not there at the end of
the as the middle of the year children
have to be moved I mean middle of the
semester so what I'm saying is and we
even go to school system cage forward
with our taxes you don't have a lot of
control over that money I have not heard
I'll make it my own ignorance right I
have not heard
of a lot of control over that money and
too many of them are just say their
diverse and do not have all the the
disciplines and the planning and
coordination in place to really deliver
a good education to children and they
get our money and they're gone or you
throw them out you don't know how much
they've ripped off the top diversity in
and of itself is needed and wonderful to
engage children in an experiential
education but my god if it isn't if it
isn't doing anything with the child if
they are not being challenging their
text boys are not showing any
improvement or they're just barely most
city don't even start on charter school
because the way the turn of the cool
thing is that the schools don't have the
experience people in the schools they
don't have enough say about what goes on
in the charter school and the charter
school is not accountable really not
really to do the schools and the schools
don't know anything about the charges
and what the charter school is doing
until they fail or the leader runs away
with the money are they find out the
water there's water in all the
classrooms in the basement and etc etc
sir this is a very new thing I'm not
signed and I'd like to I'd like to say
how much weight do we give diversity
which is definitely needed in the
approach to education the approach
without the right result is not a decent
why not let me because you said a lot
listen let me let me respond first of
all right I agree with a lot of what you
said but keep in mind I don't approach
it from the vantage point of us versus
them charter schools public charter
schools versus traditional public
schools I don't approach from that again
you know my focus is what is in the best
interest of all children that's my focus
and I agree with you if a charter school
is failing shut it down in fact it
supports the premise behind the notion
of accountability so I'm if the evidence
is clear if it's unequivocal if it's if
the empirical data search
and I mean yesterday we can't do that
with traditional schools and I want to
shut the bat ones down there too so I
grew Thal that now the other thing keep
in mind because there's a lot of rumors
and sort of misconceptions about what's
going on in traditional schools and
there's certainly rumors and
misconceptions about what's going on in
charter schools and okay what well first
of all I appreciate your commitment to
our kids because if you talk for that
long then you obviously have a heart for
kids and I appreciate that so and I'm
not this is not a hostile conversation
but but but the bear in mind that the
way charter schools laws are written
vary from state to state in the district
people generally agree that we have one
of the better written laws in the
country and I tell folks to the public
charter school board I'll tell folks to
the Board of Education if they don't do
what they promise to do shut them down
because that is the way it should be now
I can tell you there have been some
success stories with some of our charter
schools and again remember what i said
earlier ma'am i am advocating it as a
tool to prod the system to right-size
itself not as end-all be-all if we see
at the end of the day the charters
aren't the right tool or that tool needs
to be upgraded or update it i would
support that because i think that we all
have to try to very hard to refrain from
an us-versus-them attitude in terms of
how we deal with schooling because i am
all for the best school experiences for
our children and i don't care frankly
you know where is coming from as long as
it makes sense for our children yes
problems public schools how do we fix
public schools and to continue and
continue to advance the Charter at the
same time yeah I think I mean that's a
great question see I think we've got
some great public schools traditional
public schools some I mean some terrific
public schools but people who've taught
the system sure you've had your
frustrations with center administration
and the downtown bureaucracy I think
that what we have to do is is minimize
the bureaucracy of our traditional
schools I like the idea of more
autonomous schools similar to the magnet
school concept you know local school
autonomy where you pick good principles
you train them let them get their
teachers empower the teachers but
minimize the role of the downtown
central administration in the day-to-day
life of a school I think if we move
toward that you know you can even create
as I've said to you know a couple of our
superintendents you can almost create
charters within the system where you
know we had that idea similar with duke
ellington with Banneker high school in
DC and school without walls where they
had their own semi autonomy because
they've established a track record of
being able to do things the right way to
really impact on kids production so I
mean I think that we need to move toward
getting better training in place getting
teacher giving teachers support because
one of the biggest complaints I hear
from teachers in our traditional school
system is they feel like they're on
islands they're isolated that you know
one of my best examples is this teacher
stopped me to school in my ward and so
you see that bookshelf or my husband's a
carpenter he did that you see that
blackboard you know I bought that I'll
keep doing that but look so and so come
to school this little fourth grader
black and blue every day someone hit me
Matt home so also comes to school and
ain't hungry he said you know if you can
get me some social workers some
psychologists some
counselors to come in here and help with
these kids it would make a huge
difference so I do think that part of
where we need to go in terms of
supporting our public schools and even
charter schools is is having better
integration of social services into the
day-to-day existence of schools because
a lot of what our kids are facing that
gets in the way of their learning goes
beyond academic challenges it really is
some of these social challenges that you
know as a barrier to their learning yes
sir I believe is like Joe Dover Lenalee
the children to face with a barrel of a
gun and their child they get left behind
like Bill Clinton said it will even end
up in jail Darryl of the streets and you
could get these I mean some public so
you can pay for their children but don't
take money from the private school takes
a private school already making their
own Xerox Harry got books for two years
ago don't take it from them because they
are the teachers not getting paid at
these private schools they're getting
paid they teachers not going to pay but
they work today and if they great people
choose high school to college is this a
fashion show all this is the fashion
show and they stop away the fashion show
that can learn something only one in
school called our shoes I'll let the
match me Jordan I don't have this outfit
they make that uniform everybody wearing
the same clothes everybody I can't fight
over the old steals my jacket because it
on the way home I've everybody wore the
same thing to spoon every no problem is
I think the teachers get distracted
because they don't got the next lady
named grant now you know when you talk
about uniform the uniform discussion I
mean that's one that's a good example of
how the bureaucracy and the politics of
Education has been has created a barrier
to innovation well but what what
happened when people start talking my
uniforms about 10-15 years ago you had
these big school board fights and
debates where people would debate for
hours and days and weeks and months
whether to have you informed in a school
or not and then you know they had these
policies in DC with this after a couple
years of debating this we finally said
okay if a school wants to do it will let
you do it why couldn't you do that early
on see the bureaucracy is so resistant
to anything different that it really has
had an impact on on people's ability to
trust the system to educate their kids
and so the uniform is a good example I
do think that you know there's a good
argument to having uniform it's the same
thing as I mentioned earlier with
same-sex schools you know why not have
an all-male Academy you know and people
say well you know we can't do that earn
an all-girl Academy I think just I mean
let's try it and I was talking to this
guy in New York who started his own the
hundred black men in New York started
their own all-male charter school you
know and and then it and they found that
it is making making a difference so I
think you're right that that's a good
example of it may work and it works for
some kids but the system has to be
flexible enough to give us a chance to
make that work yes ma'am questions um in
your travels with in DC and across the
country
as you look to charter schools um could
you identify any three things that you
have seen that have been really really
effective and that's the first question
the second part of that question is when
the charter school movement began it was
described in a lot of ways of being some
of these areas of innovation that would
then be able to be taken and to
influence I guess sort of traditional
public education huh so how do you see
that as we're moving forward how do you
see there that bridge to be built so
that the things that we're seeing in
charter schools can influence
traditional public education are things
in traditional publication education can
influence on the charter school movement
that's excellent question goes back to
what my teacher friend over here 37
years was alluding to see I think
charter schools don't work if they start
imitating the failures of traditional
schools see if if all we can show at the
end of the day is we have a bunch of
charter schools that are doing the same
thing or the worst job then you know
that doesn't work that I mean and that's
counterproductive so one of my biggest
fears is sort of you know the
bureaucratese a shin of charters where
we we put in the same systems in the
same inherent failures that we have seen
in in traditional school districts where
there have been problems and and as I go
around the country frankly that troubles
me now a lot of it has to do some of the
laws ways some charter school laws have
been written around the country they've
been written in a way as they weren't
they were written not as a way to create
an environment that's in the best
interest of kids but it's a political
compromise document you know because
some folks thought we need to change
something in other folks didn't and he
had the teachers union involved and you
had Republicans involved and then so in
a lot of states where their charter
schools the law makes no sense
whatsoever and then you have some
fly-by-night folks to open schools you
know and there's no real accountability
I mean in some states the laws are
really loosey-goosey so as you go around
the country
people's view of what's going on and the
reality of what is going on sometimes is
unfortunately tied to the strength of
the law and that's why I think the self
policing has to take place in terms of
some of the best things I've seen around
the country I do think that there's a
real opportunity to have better school
to career offerings particularly the
high school level I've seen some
excellent programs where you know to
break out of the box kids can get their
academic offerings that they need and at
the same time when they graduate from
high school they can go right into these
careers and there have been you know
various examples st. Louis has a great
construction high school that would they
they they tie that in place there's a
great vocational high school in Houston
where they do the same thing for a lot
of our kids bear in mind you know some
may want to go to college but others
pretty much know they want to work with
their hands and I don't think most of
our school districts haven't done a good
job of meeting that knee just like the
one lady was talking about there aren't
a lot of opportunities for talented and
gifted kids similarly there aren't a lot
of opportunities for kids who have some
some real interesting desire to go into
the vocational trade secondly I think
the early childhood education I've seen
some real solid programs there's a
charter school I'm instead charter
school in Connecticut and they do an
excellent job they get those kids in
there early and they they they run them
through the gauntlet at an early age and
get kids excited about learning I think
the Kipp schools around the country have
done a good job I think the Kipp school
success is that they have they probably
do as good a job as anyone in the
country in terms of teacher training and
development so that when a teacher
enters a classroom that teacher is
pretty much ready to roll you know we
have a lot of talented and
bright young people who were interested
now in teaching but there's a real
culture shock when he hinted that
classroom and you know you gotta prepare
to go in some of these schools and deal
with some of these issues and so I do
think the more we can do to to prepare
our teachers who have a good heart and
wanted to the right thing they're young
and energetic so they don't get burned
out the more we can do the better so I
think those are some examples yes it's a
question but what I want to say the
preface is that charter schools are a
democratic principle and they're also
market-driven which I think are two of
the best things about charter schools in
that not only is their tremendous
accountability on the public level in
terms of accountability to authorize
those deliver overseas the chart asleep
but there's also parental accountability
and as a charter school parent I know
for a fact that there's Turner schools
they're not all the same obviously
they're all very unique I'm a parent
who's had a child in more than one
charters for one of them did not work
very well for my son but my niece is
thriving there he so we move into
another charter school what he's doing
exceptionally well there's some of the
charter schools that are doing better
than others have tremendous waiting
lists in some
and so I guess my question is sort of i
think that you really get it and i think
that you wanted a few public officials
who does really get it and I'm wondering
if you're going to continue to serve
students and now in some capacity the
counselors yeah I will continue to serve
and as they kicked me out of that too I
one thing you said though in terms of
best practices and I do a chapter on
this community help concept I really
think there's some utility and having
schools particularly in urban America
let's say that are really integrated
with the community this community helped
concept it's when it works it's like
magic you know and we did it ten years
ago in DC Public Schools and I and I
Chronicle that experience in the chapter
here where it was a good thing but then
the bureaucracy messed it up because
they said I want to do that or you gave
that tape that principal over there
autumn resources I want social services
in my school the community helped
concept means that there's just a full
assortment of city services in the
school and so I know that the community
academy which I featuring here run by
Kent Amos there an example of it but ten
years ago the we had one of the best
examples that Patricia Roberts Harris
where Linda McKay was the principal
there and you know she had a crime rat
community her first week on the job they
found a body in front of her school she
found like 20 or 30 guns in the building
and she decided she was going to get
work a partnership out with the city and
get some social services in there it was
like magic yet these partners come in
she had computer training she had
businesses come in the school did not
shut down at three she had social
services she had nurses she had doctors
she had folks taking parents with their
taking GED classes at seven eight
o'clock at night they had job training
they're going on that employers coming
in hiring parents so at seven eight nine
o'clock at night you could have a PTA
meeting with 200 parents you know who
would be already been taking computer
classes and GED classes it was a it was
a true community hub and I do think that
more and more schools have to be
flexible to be open to that type of
community engagement because if you're
able to bring parents into the process
and into the fold and they get energized
by it then that does trickle down and
you almost have sort of some
give-and-take both ways for the parents
fire up the kids and the kids drop the
parents and everybody's getting
something out the deal and the school
system the city should be should be
working jointly in that way yes ma'am
question she was talking about her
responsibilities I'd like to ask you in
our country we talk about education as
if it's sort of in a vacuum that it can
simply be operated by screen and parts
of education and I don't hear much about
Carolyn loudly because to get paranoid
involvement is up it's more and more
challenging and it's
to school just quit reading that job
they're just trying to do it all
themselves I'm wondering how much do you
think like that community school concept
which is very old and it grew out of the
civil rights act when they started
trying to meet all the nice rub kids
it's rather than breakfast too right ah
but I'm wondering we talk about schools
without talking about the challenge of
engaging parents it's cool thing to have
quit really trying to engage Peter on
how much can we do in that because kids
don't grow up in a bank you know and
they learn better with that beer that's
why the zone of homeschooling everybody
know that won't work the kids love it
yeah and the schools are even opening up
so that they can do sports and
scientific labs as you know away from
home better the children learn more
quickly so if we're not going to meet
the challenge of parents are weak will
we ever really be able to have a good
responded result academic a frightened
children that's an excellent question
look the reality is if every parent were
engaged school all schools would work
you know not I'm just starting from this
premise okay I mean the reality is if
every parent we're engaged all schools
would work that speaks to your main
point that yes and engaged parent is the
most important aspect but we know
unfortunately that's not the reality you
know I face that that realization
several years ago I said okay no I know
no but no I know i don't--are from a
theoretical construct I mean I'm working
my way to Marie ya know I know I'm
working my way I'm working my way to you
okay I'm just I'm yeah no no I'm like
them preachers I skipping no steps oh I
mean you know we gotta link it but I
skip enough okay you're there but
someone might be watching may skip it
you know I don't want to skip it no okay
shoot I mean there's a lot of people I
don't think appreciate the depths of
what you're talking about because again
most people aren't engaged a dating
schools most people in fact allow the
policymakers their kids have been out of
school for 20 years they don't know
what's going on day to day they don't
really know how bad some of the social
conditions are in these communities so
we can skip steps you understand I
understand but for a lot of Americans
it's just what they read in the paper or
see on TV so my point is that if you're
I think again bear with me if every
single parent were engaged day to day
all schools work because they were
demanded but the reality is we've gone
to the other extreme where so many
parents are so disengaged that that's
contributed to a lot of schools not
working and then you have good teachers
who see what's going on and good
principles that see what's going on and
they try to step in to feel the boy and
they can't because you know a teacher
can't replace a parent as much as you
try you can't sew it from a public
policy perspective it puts us in a
quandary because we say all right we
can't raise kids who aren't being raised
every kid does not being raised but this
is where the innovation and creativity
is even more essential because if we
know that there's a large growing
segment of the population of totally
disengaged parents and kids who aren't
being raised but they're just growing up
and they are in our schools then we have
got to find ways different in ways that
were put in effect during the 1890s to
educate them and and the challenge is we
have to update our approach to social
services you know we had this issue in
DC where we had to immunize kids and we
said you know what we got 30,000 kids
have been immunized and Willian Iseman
for free we said notices home
kids sent notice I mean took noses home
you know we sit warnings out and you
know maybe 5,000 got immunized you know
we still had 25,000 left we threaten
folks your kid can't go to school maybe
two or three thousand more we're never
about 17,000 kids and you know what we
ended up doing we got social workers we
got the police we got the roving leaders
from Department recreation we got city
workers who were sitting behind a desk
and we went knocked on doors and then
when we knocked on doors and we found
out parents that oh yeah I saw that but
one I couldn't read it or you know I
figured I'll take care of it and then we
found that their kids 15 16 17 years of
age we hadn't been to a dentist or
doctor since they were born so when
you're dealing with that level of
reality then you're right it we can't do
it all but what we can do is create an
environment that's more flexible to try
to deal with some of those needs that we
can address from in this case
perspective and then the city agencies
you know again this is part of the
bureaucratic tug-of-war city agencies
social service agencies state agencies
you know they cannot have that desk
mentality you know we've got to have
more aggressive I think blending of
social services with school services and
folks have to be in the community taking
the services to the people so you're
absolutely right interstate is is it is
something that this country has to come
to grips with the biggest fear though is
that if we don't come up with creative
ways of dealing with this problem then
the uneducated will continue to have
uneducated and continue to have
uneducated and that cycle will continue
to grow and then we frankly would be
facing a situation where a lot of our
own will be predators and as some of the
signs that we're seeing and I think we
have to be honest about that yes ma'am
there's a commercial on TV
dig into Charles Barkley and he asks the
audience do you know my name do you know
my record do you know what a team I
played for and then do you know your
parent your child's teacher how can the
private sector get into helping with
bringing parents back into being an
active participant and that was sort of
ultimate question I got caught up but I
do think that you know the end of my
initial remarks I talked about that we
all have to play a vested row we have to
become as I said educated about
education we have to be able to
challenge the rhetoric that folks like
me and other folks throw out to you you
know you got to ask questions you can't
just accept it the problem is we don't
know enough even to ask the right
questions so we can't even challenge
what we're being told if President Bush
are senator Kerry tell us you know I'm
for public education this is what i'm
going to do half of America has to
accept what they say because they don't
know what they're talking about and you
know that can't work it just we can't
let the folks who are responsible for
running our schools and funding our
schools we can't let them off the hook
including me I mean I'm open to the
challenges but we can't let them off the
hook by accepting what they tell us so
we all have to be more engaged and I
tell you one of the biggest I opening
experience is that if you if you live in
your community is to visit your
neighborhood school get involved a
little bit walk in on a PTA meeting you
know go to the school event go to the
school you know sporting event just just
take in an eyeful in an earful and and
then you'll you'll you'll get some
better understanding and then I do think
that we need to engage some of these
folks that young people can relate to
but not just young people the young
parents can relate to as well I think
we'll take one more questions I don't
want to sign some books any other
questions yes
but relates to talk about education I
don't know if anyone talk about the
stadium and just a little messages that
are being sent with you know for example
that evil is a DC filtration even though
there is no physical school in DC and I
know it's been discussed within the
company that you know just public funds
I think 24 to 26 million dollars will
come from tax on businesses that we'd be
used to help fund the stadium right I
know I've been discussed at you know
either cut he was going to leave DC a
will somebody go to jail because we're
not giving them money for no stadium not
that you know I love sports myself but I
just can't see that when we have schools
in such horrible condition and my take
one it is you know is this man we're
concerned about his legacy that he can
leave as mayor and say this is what i
did i brought this stadium or should you
be more concerned with saying well it
may have taken ten years to turn the
schools around but the process started
when i was in office I mean I Thommo
Thommo saving lives versus having a
stadium come that's going to benefit not
poor people and not working class people
but primarily well-to-do middle class
they make it 100 seats or some poor
people outside they do it so again poor
people and working class black folks
have been shafted all the time all this
development in DC as people are excited
about them benefit cool people over a
pleasure on our feet well so I mean it's
the same old song well let me just say
that you know I dedicated my public
career to fixing schools at did against
the advice of anyone who knows anything
about political lives and political
futures because people in the know will
tell you the worst thing you can do is
get involved in trying to fix education
if you want a political future so I mean
I have I dedicated my life to that
because I thought it was the right thing
to do and in that regard is chair of the
Education Committee on the council we
added more money to schools and it was a
fight than at any time in history we had
a four hundred million dollars to DC
Public Schools new money over
a five-year period when they got when
they lost 10,000 students so they had
ten thousand fewer students and 400
million new dollars now I'm proud of
that what I'm not proud of is how the
money was spent which I think that
bureaucracy gobbled it up I'm also proud
of the fact that we were building more
new schools and libraries and recreation
centers than at any time in the city's
history but then again the bureaucracy
messed that up because you know we gave
the school system money to build schools
and then the cost overruns they spent
five or ten times what they suppose two
on one school you know so it that the
whole bureaucracy associated with even
putting good money or you know good
intentions and good money to the problem
is wrapped around some of the
inefficiencies that we've seen in
bureaucracy now on as it relates to to
the to the mayor the mayor and I've had
our challenges you know over the years I
mean I renting us America so but but on
the stadium issue I am glad that one
thing we did that really was to report
it while you know we put in place
this-this-this taxing scheme on
businesses we also put in a requirement
to look at this private financing piece
so that you know we can get some private
financing to offset a lot of that public
cost down the road and and none of that
really should be at the expense of the
new schools and the new libraries and
recreations I think the most important
thing we need to do if we're going to
build new schools in DC then we need to
get the right people running the money
because I mean I got so frustrated with
the money that we allocated not being
spent the way it should be spent and and
and that's why I think that calls in
question whether school officials should
be handling school construction issues
or whether we should hire professionals
to
that let the school folks you know
educate deal with the academics and the
day to day and they can have final sign
off on any designs and everything but I
don't think I'll of educators but I
don't necessarily trust an educator be
an architect and you know and I think
that's been part of the problem as well
so anyway I do want to thank kuriboh
books for all that you all have done I
mean this is this is a phenomenal
phenomenal vision that has come to bear
I would love to see y'all in the city
and maybe we do some special purpose
legislation so y'all won't be taxed for
the stadium but uh I want to thank and
that's on the record you can I can't
deny it but I really want to thank you
all for what you're doing i want to
thank those of you who came you know i'm
heartened by by what we can accomplish
and for those of you didn't come i read
a passage in the book in the end that I
stand by and I live by and that is in
spite of all of our adult debates and
fights over this issue you know our
biggest resource and the biggest reason
for hope and optimism are the kids we
say we serve because I'm kids I tell you
they are open and eager to learn and we
I think we should dedicate our lives to
making sure they all get what they
deserve thank you all very much i'm
going to sign some books thank you
appreciate it thank you junko pete
walker street
madam teacher I want you shake my
serving our children charter schools in
the reform of American public education
is published by capital books visit
capital dash books calm for more
information